NOT TO REFER, COULD COME A
SUN
HERE'S S WITH THE ANDFUL OF DOLD
FORMER AIDES
>> THEY CHEATED WITH THE
MACHINES.
LECIIOLARK.E  MORNING.ter: COUL
COMMITTEVE
JANUARY 6tE U.S.E CONSIDERING
FERRALS FOHITE HOUSE
LAWYER JN EASTMAN,
JUSTICE DEPAICL K, AND
TOY GIULIAURNNE WANT TO MAKE SUE
WEE SURET TH
KEY ORGAZE
ATTACK DOT ESCAPE
SCRU OE SYSTEM.
>> Reporter: THE S
TO REFER
BUT THE COMMITTEE HOPES TOAND W.
THS  O
MAKE
DE ABOUTON OF CRIMINAL REFLS
AT THIS SUNDAY MEETIHAT'S THE P
REPORTED THE COMMITT
PRENFO
SERIOUSLY. IVET MAKING A REFERRF
>> Reporter: THE COMMITTEE
AIMINGO RELEASE ITS FINAL
RE IT OF CRIMINAL
RERRR .
>> TRE WILL SND OF A
PUBLIC-FACING EVENT.
>> Reporter: AS THE COMMITTEE
WRAPS UP IOR FORMER
PR FACING LEGA
JEOPARDY ONUFRONTS.
>> THE CASE AGAINST E FORMER
PRIDS WORSE AN
RS
>> H
FOR THE PLOT TO TRY TO U020 ELE
SENSITIVE GOVERN D
AFTER LEAVINE WHITE FBREVE
MAR-A-LAGON AUGUT'S NOT A CRIME
IMMEDIATELCK
THEY'VE TAKEN FROM MUSE
IT'S MINE.
>> Reporter: A SQU A FIR T
LAWYERS VEO MORE
TH CLASSIFIED
MARKINGSA IDAG
TRUMP DECIDED TO
ASK THE SUEM REVIEWING THE
EVIDENCE FROM MAR-A-LAGO, A CE
THE
PARTY
CONTEMPT FOR FAINGO COMPLY MENTU
T SUBP O
THISL HAPPENECRET  BUT
AGAIN, ALL B DOORS, ON FE A
JUDGE WIONTER.IF HELONTEMP
POST-PRESIDENCY OFFICE COULD
KE
>>
Y, THANKS SO MUCH.
S.
MY AUGUSTEL
KAT ER THESE MES AGAI T IS
CONSIDERING REFRLS FOR FORMEE H
AD,
OFFICIAL JEFFREY CLA, TTORNE .
>>.UR REPORTING.
LO, T I N'
THERE'S ANRPRISES TRUL
THAT LIST.
PAICU ARE ATTORN-
Y  IN.BUT WHETHER THIS MATTERS Y
LANHOE  ML
REED S OUT ABOUT WHYST NOT
INFORM TE THAT THEY'SK
FOR.
RE FEN
AN GET
ABOUT >> OTHE THINGS THAS
RE A,  T FT
THAT THERE AREO ROVIDED EVIDENC
INFORMATION TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTH APPAREN
JUSTD TO.
WITNESSES TAKE SOME OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITHY
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMEIGHT.
BE WAR
ECHAT BECAUSE ICALLY IS NOT AS
D.S NOT INVESTATE
THIS, THEY'VIOUS
>>E HAD IN
SUBPOENAS TO SWING SWHERE
THFAS BEING PUSHED.
JACK SMITH
>> THEPENSEL.
ISOLATION D WELL, AT
REFERRALS, ET
FAIRLY SOON SPE N NVESTION G ONW
WHICH HE'SG WHERE
GSLYO
CRITICIZED RIGHTOR PGA THEORISTA
THBOUT THES ATTHIA.
AND HOLOCAUSDENIERS. IN --  INA
- I DON'EV
SMOOTHLYO T. ANNOUNNT-ELECT, ITH
SURE WHO'S STEERING THE
ANLY OPLE AROD TH
PRESID
THE PRESIDT HIMSELF.
BUT HOW IS TINS RUNN IT T SEEMSN
NNE CO A
ON DOWN THERE
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> OUR
OUT WITH WHITET WITHNTI-SEC PEO.
I DON'T GET IT., HE SHOULD JUSTO
NG ABOUTHIAS TO HE WEST.
DISAGREE
Y ANAN
FOR.
.E'K HE WIL
AND M NOT RPI
DON'T NY HIGH EXPECTATIONSSI
I THINK HE'S SPIRALINGN'T THINK
ANYONE BUT THE H
HEAD.
AND I MORE AND
BUT I DON'T KNOW
TRUMP WILL GO AWAY.
>> HE'S NOD WE'LONE STEPS UP
RY CONTT HIM IN
AND IF NOTLI EAOUBLE IF
E THE HEADLINE.
THAY TIS
INTERESTINSTS FTREPUBLICANS KES
COMMITTEETRNND
MIGHT TRD ESTING TO SEE HOW EY
HEADLINES WITH SOME HE
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'
INTERESTING IS THAT --
TRUMP MEETING WITH
NNE CONW.SITANS YED NI
>> I WOULD LIKE TOR
FROM H
I WOULD LIKE T THE ONLY
PERSON FROM THE ADMINIRA
LAO BENEFIs WITH
LLLD BE  F
>> WOW.NAREXPECTED TO.
>> THAWAANHT.
>> YES.A VERY INTERES -SPECIAVE
O IS WONDERING WHO'S
ITLL.D HIM, S
ACTIN
AND AT THIS POINT EVERY ACTION Y
VERY EASTO N BE INCAUSE IT'S
TH
>> ELY'S NOT DISTANCING HIMSELF.
TH WHOBES HOLOCAUST DENIAL
AND ANTI-SEMM
>>H.R SUPPORT.
E LENGTH H
FR NOTALIENATEIS JT  SUPPORT
REMARKAB
HE CLEARS EMBRACING .
I MEANS THE BIG
REMEMBER W MEBODY STOOD UP AND E
AINER
SAID NO, WE'REOT THAT.UP AND HE
RIGHT?
AND THAT'S RTH
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN DONALUMAND M.
THERE'S ALWAYS
INS BELI
MANY OF THESE TERRIBLE THINGS,
HAS HWS, THAT
HAVE BEEN TIT THE DIFFERENCE IS
LEADERS HAVE BEEN WILLING TO
AND THE ITIS
LISTEN TO OUAD
AMERICANS NOO THINK THE
ELTI STOLEN, BECAUSE
W  AND THAT'S
TELLING THE FACT HE'S NOT DO-
MATTERS A LOT.
ORM GLAD WE'REOCUSINON
LIKE W THIYMORE.WE NEED TO MOVEY
, NDA ON'TIS TRUMPYMORE, W T
CKALL TRUM
CA- THERE WAS  C WE HAD UP BE
AFTER TRLOTHAT MESSAGE DOES NOT-
PEOP W THIS.
SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE REJEC
VOTERS REJECT IS.HOPEMEREPUBLIC
SAYS WE REJECT IT VEOTHERWWE
WIN.
P
EN YOU THINK  REALLY CLOSEMEAN,O
WASN'T.AS IN RUFFWARNOCK COULDN%
HI KASIE'S
LDENED AND CONTINU BE  WITH TRU
ON THAT COMPONENT
REPUBLICAN PARTY BY LONG
%,ATERU THROUGH A Y,
RENOT BULK OF THE
>> BUT GETTING THROUGH A PRIMARY
OW REPUBN
LEGO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
SURE BUTWH, AKINFO
KIYI GUY -- JARED KUSHNE
BENEFITED, HE MADE A O
MONEFR FATHER-INAWTE HSE'SY TAK
HEY, THIS ISN HE IS  MOST ENT
JEWISH MEMBE FORMEADMINISTRATI